سانجاي إذن ، ما هو تحليلك بناءً على
كل ما نعرفه ، هل يمكن أن يكون اللقاح
الذي كنا ننتظره جميعًا من
الممكن أن يأتي
خلال الأشهر العديدة القادمة ، حسنًا
إذا كنت أعتقد أنه لا يوجد شيء في هذه
الدراسة الأولى التي راجعها الأقران الآن  منا
مرشح لقاح ، لا يوجد شيء في
الدراسة يشير إلى أن أي شيء قد
خرج عن مساره ، لكن ما زالت الأيام الأولى جدًا من
أيام وولف ، دعني
أخبرك ببعض الأشياء حول هذا الأمر ، لقد
أعطوا جرعة من اللقاح إلى
45 فردًا يتمتعون بصحة جيدة تتراوح أعمارهم
بين 18 عامًا  و 55 ثم أعطوا جرعة ثانية
بعد حوالي شهر بعد 28 يومًا ،
لذا تذكر أن هذا هو
لقاح مكون من جرعتين يبحثون فيه
هنا لمحاولة الحصول على الاستجابة
التي يأملون
أنها بدت آمنة نسبيًا  مما يعني أنه
لم تكن هناك آثار جانبية كبيرة
أوقفت التجربة فعليًا ولكن
دعني أوضح لك ما إذا كان بإمكاني فقط بعض
الآثار الجانبية التي رأوها
وأعطوها هذا الدواء بجرعات مختلفة -
الجرعة
والجرعة الأعلى بشكل أساسي كان لدى كل
شخص حصل على اللقاح
نوع من الآثار الجانبية ، كان لدى بعض الأشخاص
أكثر من تأثير جانبي واحد
بدا أنهم عابرون ، لكنهم ذهبوا بعيدًا ولكن مرة أخرى
ذئبوا هذه الجوانب  التأثيرات هي شيء
سوف ينتبهون إليه
وكان هذا في 45 شخصًا سليمًا
تتراوح أعمارهم بين 18 و 55 عامًا ، حيث
يسير الذئب سريعًا خلال المرحلة
الأولى وسيبدأون المرحلة
الثالثة في نهاية هذا الشهر
عادةً ما يستغرق ذلك سنوات للوصول إلى
هذه النقطة ومن الواضح أنهم فعلوا
ذلك في شهور السؤال الكبير الذي يطرحه
الذئب في العمل بشكل صحيح هو أنه في
الواقع سيوفر الحماية حتى
لا يصاب الناس بهذا الفيروس
ونحن لا نفعل ذلك  لا تعرف الإجابة على
ذلك حتى الآن ، إذا كان هذا اللقاح يبدو
أنه يصنع أجسامًا مضادة في الأشخاص الذين
تم إعطاؤه لهم ، ولكن إلى أي مدى
ستعمل هذه الأجسام المضادة علينا أن ننتظر
ونرى من خلال هذه التجارب الأخرى ، هناك
الشيء الذي تعرفه أنت الذئب  أحب أن يكون لديك
نوع من القياس الكورالي عند إجراء
هذه التجارب ، مثل أنني أحب قياس
شيء ما بالبوصة أو الجنيهات أو الأمتار ،
للأسف ليس لدينا ذلك ، لذا
لا يمكنني إخبارك أن هذا يعمل
بشكل جيد X مبلغ حتى الآن  الطريقة الوحيدة لمعرفة الحقيقة
هذا هو دراسة هذا
ومجموعات أكبر وأكبر من الأشخاص ومعرفة ما إذا
كانت تحميهم في الواقع ، وهذا هو
الأساس الذي سيكونون عليه
الآن خلال الأشهر العديدة القادمة ضد الذئب الذي
يبدأ في نهاية هذا
الشهر لاكتشاف
يبدو أنه يبدو آمنًا بشكل عام ،
فلنتأكد من بقائه آمنًا عند كبار السن
والأشخاص الذين يعانون من ظروف موجودة مسبقًا
، ودعنا نتأكد أيضًا من
أنه يعمل على حماية الأشخاص
من عدوى الذئب
، أريد أن أسألك عن هذا الموضوع
نظرًا لأنه من المحتمل أن يكون الخبر مزعجًا ،
فإن دراسة جديدة وجدت أن
الأجسام المضادة لفيروس كورونا لدى الشخص بعد
تعرضهم بالفعل للمرض
وطوروا أجسامًا
مضادة تبدأ تلك الأجسام المضادة في الانخفاض في مكان ما بعد 20
إلى 30 يومًا من ظهور الأعراض لأول مرة ،
فهذا يعني إذا كان شخص ما مصابًا بالمرض.
يمكن للأجسام المضادة أن تنخفض
وربما تختفي في النهاية ، فهل هذا يعني
أن الناس يمكن أن يصابوا بهذا المرض أكثر
من مرة.
بالنسبة إلى هذا السؤال في
الوقت الحالي ، هل تعلم أننا لا نعرف على وجه اليقين
، سأقول هذا Jake ونحن نتابع هذا
عن كثب ، ونقوم بالكثير من
التقارير في هذا المجال الذي تعرفه في هذه
المرحلة في منتصف شهر يوليو.
شاهدت تقارير حالة عن
إصابة الأشخاص بالعدوى مرة أخرى في هذا البلد ، حسنًا ،
كان هناك بعض النقاش حول ذلك في
كوريا الجنوبية ربما لم يكن في الواقع
إعادة العدوى الحقيقية x 'إذا كان صحيحًا
أن الأجسام المضادة والحماية كانتا تدومان فقط من
20 إلى 30 يومًا ، أعتقد أننا سنفعل ذلك.
بدأنا في رؤية بعض
الكميات الكبيرة من إعادة العدوى التي
لم نكن في المرتبة الثانية ، وهي أنك تعرف
فكرة أن الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
أعراض طفيفة مقابل الأشخاص الذين
لديهم أعراض كبيرة يبدو أنهم
يمتلكون كميات مختلفة من الأجسام المضادة
التي ينتجونها.  تم إثباته
في دراستين من الصين واحدة
من إيطاليا الآن ، لذا فإن الأشخاص الذين لا تظهر عليهم
أعراض نسبيًا أو يعانون من أعراض طفيفة
قد ينتجون
أجسامًا مضادة أقل وربما يكونون
مضادات أقل قوة.  الهيئات أيضًا مرة أخرى ،
لا تزال البيانات ترد حول هذا الأمر ، لذا يتعين
علينا أن نرى ذلك ، وأعتقد
أن السؤال الكبير في المستقبل
هو أنك تعرف مدى الحماية في
نهاية المطاف إذا تعرضت
لهذا الفيروس وأعتقد أن الإجابة
لا تزال أن لديك بعض الحماية
لفترة من الوقت قد لا يكون
الجسم المضاد على وجه التحديد ، فقد تكون هذه
الخلايا الأخرى هي التي تنشط بسرعة في
الجسم لتكوين الأجسام المضادة عندما
تتعرض  الفيروس الذي لا نعرفه حتى الآن ،
لكنني أعتقد أن جيك بناءً على جميع
التقارير التي تفيد بأنه على الأقل لفترة من
الوقت لديك حماية
بعد تعرضك لهذا الفيروس ،
يُعتقد أن كوفات 19 ينتشر بشكل أساسي من
خلال الاتصال الوثيق من شخص  إلى
شخص لكن مركز السيطرة على الأمراض يقول إن بعض الأشخاص الذين
ليس لديهم أعراض قد يكونون قادرين على
نشر الفيروس ، أظهر تقرير حديث في مجلة الأمراض المعدية الناشئة في مركز السيطرة على
الأمراض
أن ما يصل إلى نصف السكان
المصابين بفيروس كورونا ومرافق الرعاية طويلة الأجل
في باسادينا كالي
لم تظهر على Fornia أي أعراض وكان ربع
الموظفين المصابين أيضًا بدون أعراض
، نظر الفريق إلى تسعة مرافق رعاية طويلة الأجل
في المدينة وحدد
معدل الإصابة بدون أعراض بين الموظفين
في المتوسط كان واحدًا من كل أربعة وواحد من كل اث
ين بين السكان الذين وجدوا إن
ثًا.  كان لدى سكان دور رعاية المسنين
معدلات أعلى من العدوى بدون أعراض مقارنة
بالسكان الذكور ، ويقولون لأن
احتمالية الانتقال بدون أعراض
تتعلق بجهود مكافحة العدوى
ويجب أن تشمل مرافق الرعاية طويلة الأجل
كلاً من الاختبارات الجماعية وفحص الأعراض
للدقيقة الصحية
الحالية.